[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
really excited to be talking about
closing the loop on currency about
designing our future we have Ray Potter
joining us what's up man what's up man
thank you for coming on the show yes
thank you for having me really excited
to talk about this topic
I love how deeply you've been studying
civilization to figure this out
because this is one of the most pressing
things we can do is figure out how to
design this so that like you're gonna go
through and teach us that the way we
design currency is the way we design our
life the way we humanize each other the
way that we can best move forward so I'm
pumped yeah me too and so you know it's
it's some very interesting times that
we're living in right now and just
coming to the studio today with both of
these fires raging in near San Francisco
area and in LA and seeing the the
fallout of that and we're seeing all of
these kind of catastrophic events and
how we approach that which lens we look
at it is it is it my problem is it your
problem or is it our problem and that's
kind of at the root of how we look at
the problems that are in front of us
whether we see them as insurmountable
challenges or we see them as something
that we can actually see the whole thing
the whole picture and close the loop on
how we can move forward I like the way
that you think about things and I think
your background gives us a really good
understanding of the way you started
thinking about things I like calling you
like a systems thinker a design thinker
you think things through run like a very
more of like an abstract scale
calculating as
any variables as possible and then
thinking about how it's gonna affect the
people that are using it so why don't we
talk a bit about how you started to get
into interest about this so give us a
bit on that before we go really deep
yeah so my background is as a creative
professional well many layers you know I
think I think from a young age just the
way things are set up never really made
sense to me I didn't really understand
why we had organized things in a
particular order you know why some
somebody's life is more important than
somebody else's life
it just y-you know there's things like
discrimination or things like lack of
opportunity and I'll tell you kind of
you know where that comes from I was you
know born and brought up in India for
the first ten years of my life and a lot
of that time I spent in rural India
where my grandparents and actually
seeing a lot of capacity a lot of talent
in the local kids but didn't have a view
of the city life or view of what is
possible so that's you know one aspect
of growing up to my formative years and
then coming here you know we basically
had the whole immigrant story so now I'm
in this place and this little brown kid
that does not speak English and kind of
learning that stuff on the fly and and
then realizing that we went through this
whole these economic loops of coming
through very difficult neighborhoods up
into a very privileged neighborhood and
the contrast from both of those things
were very striking to me and I said I
don't understand why these kids that are
super talented and creative don't get
the opportunity where these kids that
grow up with privilege get all the
opportunity in the world and they
squander it so I guess it's the way of
the world you think about that but it's
it always bothered me so for my whole
life as as a professional creative
professional being a designer art
director creative director
and then in the 90s I was here in the
Bay Area got a very lucky very fortunate
to work on first of all kind of things
before there are things the first social
networks the first multi-sided
marketplaces the VoIP apps a lot of
things or you know even even what you'd
call narrow cast cable you know all of
those kinds of things were part of my
professional upbringing and I lived and
worked all over the world and and you
get to see many sensibilities of how
people live how they see the world how
they perceive things and and the the
lack that that the the inequity in
equity of access in equity of access yet
the abundance of talent capacity
everywhere so this whole growing up as a
designer a creative communicator product
designer systems architect this was part
of my professional life and what
happened back around 2008-2009 time is
we got involved in a project I was at a
fancy title for a designer which was you
know director of digital innovation for
a company that did a lot of work for big
systems you know municipalities energy
systems and so on and so during that
time I was kind of leading a project
that was about architecting the energy
efficiency education of what is the
future of energy and all of that right
so so he produced the thing and the end
result of that was basically questioning
the some assumptions about the way we
use energy and the underlying economic
premise behind what types of energy
generation harvesting distribution
technologies are actually available
versus what is how we actually use and
burn fossil fuels and what that whole
extractive game or this economic game is
about and so many things occurred to me
at that time at the time I wrote a book
had no idea about writing a book
and so you know but the right people got
a chance to read it and that started my
quest for this last decade or so really
trying to understand at a systemic level
what is going on underneath the hood you
know what is behind the curtain of Oz
that is making us do the things that we
do now we're at this really interesting
juncture in in civilization where things
don't make sense you know I don't know
who to trust I don't know what where
things are going I can't predict what
tomorrow looks like you know next week
looks like next year looks like and it's
making people a little crazy and so for
me to kind of come full circle is that
it's really looking at the whole picture
understanding what's iterating at the
root and understanding you know where
the gap is and see if we can fill this
gap with a new way of viewing how we
interact with each other that's kind of
that's kind of where I'm coming from
yeah like how your background was
exactly what you needed to figure out
how to look under the hood yeah and or
past the veil yeah and I see what's
going on because why we do what we do is
really important to understand instead
of just doing it like why are we doing
it so then picking currency yeah how did
that happen
so you know the one of the key things
that was very obvious to me going
through this exercise of understanding
decentralized innovations in the energy
space and why some really breakthrough
things we're not coming to the forefront
you know things amazing technologies
using friction kinetics motion you know
all these ways of capturing and
repurposing energy that was available
technologically but not available to
tool to us and so and and so you start
to look at the underlying economic game
who is grandfathered in and whose
project gets green lighted and whose
project does not and what is the flow of
capital you know who creates the money
and how does that money get distributed
and how does that affect the rest of us
right and so it's a very interesting you
know instrument of money and when I when
I look
that you know it's old saying follow the
money right so you can follow the money
and you see that it's kind of you know
rotted at the roots in in terms of its
foundational assumptions and in terms of
its use it tell us why okay
so currently the instrument of money and
I'll come back one so you asked me the
very direct questions why why money so I
think the design of currency is really
the design of civilization it is the way
we're civil to one another is the
agreement field in which we operate
right yeah and so so so now to this
question what you just asked me is that
we have been very good at proving the
promise of money in other words you know
the instrument of money that we use
that's why it's called a promissory note
it's a promise against which something
is going to get produced okay and the
structure is okay I have this capacity
to make more promises more choices
because I hold this instrument I've
created this instrument against which
people will do work okay so this trust
around this and call it a national bond
if this is an agreement that this much
work will be done against this promise
or instrument that we use for exchange
you know a store of value credit all
these kinds of things right well that
stuff is backed by an elaborate set of
guesswork called gross domestic
production right so we don't really know
if that's going to be produced
whether that's supposed to be produced
whether that producing that actually
benefits society as a whole and then
it's another precarious instrument that
the in and of itself is in debt in other
words it's a debt instrument meaning I
don't know the second part which is the
most interesting part is that what is
the production against that promise in
other words what is the proof of
performance against the proof of promise
that we so readily generate now whether
it is Fiat or crypto were very good at
creating this
what promise you know this crypto coin
promises to do XYZ you know and you and
and you see what happened in the ico
market which is very interesting very
much like a dot-com bubble this is one
Bitcoin is worth this amount of dollars
this was the amount of dollars and the
logic behind that you know and or
blockchain will sell the you know save
the world is 12 lines of code on Python
we rearranged that as to who gets their
transaction pass through why and so you
reckon with the banking system even with
yeah it's a digital ledger yeah but
coming down to but something very very
basic these are the routes that were
these are these are the routes something
very very basic ok so what's really
interesting about the construct of money
is from the from the game of where it's
created to how where it's implemented
and how it's used
so in our lives okay if I borrow five
bucks from you and you want that five
dollars back the five dollars that you
give gave me actually comes from that
there's a there's a proof of both
production and there's the performance
you've performed something or you
produce something in order for you to
have that money okay when you give it to
me you also expect me to perform
something or produce something against
it so between me and you that kind of
loop exists even though it's it's not
you know clean it's not really a readily
understood it's not clear but that thing
exists when an institution took a non
formal verbal agreement it's a non
formal verbal agreement right so it
exists but even the formation of that
how I have that money in my pocket how
you have that money in your pocket is
something that we've done in order for
us to have it I performed Gotham I
perform something there's a proof of
performance form to build a relationship
but early enough to where I trusted you
correct correct so you've performed
something you produce something you know
whether it's within within this GDP
framework or not you produce something
and you perform something so you have it
I have it and you expect
that from me back from me right now when
a bank produces that they don't have to
perform anything there have to prove
their performance you just believe in
the promise and you have more promise
making and choice making capacity as a
result of you being the design architect
of this instrument right so I can just
invent money out of thin air
and in fact that is essentially what
happens this is the reason why we have
the idea of inflation in the first place
right so I can keep making promises
against which you produce you can keep
on producing against that promise now
that thing never reconciled and I have
more and more promise making and choice
making capacity if I'm on the capital
side of things we all work for capital
so whether in the shark tank and I'm
giving you money and your hard work that
you invented something you know I give
60% of my company to you because now I
have more promise making and choice
making capacity you don't so and then
the return that I'm gonna get on that
investment is gonna give me more promise
making and choice making capacity and
you won't have it
same thing with the employee employer
relationship I hold I hold the ticket I
hold a bio survival ticket call money
and that thing against which you will
perform and I will have more of it at
the end of it so I'll have more promise
making capacity more choice making
capacity without being able to prove my
performance I don't have to prove my
performance I'm above it okay hence we
have this whole thing of the 1% none
that people are aware of the scenario of
this dramatic gap in wealth dramatic
black gap dramatic inequality and the
dramatic effect on the environment right
now we're running up against some very
you know serious existential challenges
climate change political instability all
of these kind of craziness things that
are going on in the world where people
are going okay but I have the money well
how good is that money tomorrow right so
even the current money supply based on
this promise making capacity rather than
proving the ability to
actually produce against it okay the
proof of performance is not in the money
and so proof of performance not being
accountable to the centralized
institutions that manage our knowledge
the manage our our media manage the
distribution of wealth all these things
are are not accountable to produce
and/or perform against the promise or
instruments that they're creating this
creates a huge huge gap in the way
things work and it's you work more and
you earn less or you think you earn more
but things cost more as a result okay so
you're in this perpetual loop of
continuously having to produce because
it's already not stacked in your favor
if I have the promise her promise making
capacity I'm always going to be ahead of
you and the irony of that is if I have a
lot of promise making capacity I'm a
billionaire trillionaire or whatever I'm
not happy because I think all of you
guys want my [ __ ] okay if I don't have
anything I'm not happy either
so either either scenario we are unhappy
and what is the point of living if both
ways of existing is now reconciling
itself right and so the idea of create
closing the loop on currency is to
basically close the promise making to
the production of it in other words
proof of performance against the proof
of promise when you can close that loop
now you can fundamentally start to
change the way we interact with each
other the way we interact with and we
could we'll unpack that but yeah but
that's that's the basic setup it seems
to be permeating through culture the
notion that money is so important to
climb up this hierarchy earn money make
a living and then you make that money
and then we see so many people get
caught up in materialism or some sort of
depressive state or some sort of
inability to hoot on who to trust people
at the bottom of the socio-economic
strata are like thinking that
gosh I can barely afford a food or you
barely afford something like him just
clean to the bottom of the hierarchy so
there just seems to be something wrong
with the root system of money because we
see that evolve yeah so just seeing that
evolve says at least something about the
root system of money that there is not
there's not a there's not an there's not
an equilibrium of of planetary thriving
that's occurring there just there's
there's a lot of of military industrial
complexes there's a lot of of
corporations that are aiming to
manipulate people there's there's
sacrificing the health and ecology of
the planet so because of all of those
things it just it looks you look back at
the root system and you think ok how can
it be augmented to build a better future
alright so now with proof of performance
we're thinking ok now rather than give
can we go back to the five dollar
example I already performed something a
value to get the money like you try you
have gained trust with me perform to get
trust right I give you the five dollars
and then this is a now how is this
system related to this new architecture
that you want to make based on
performance so what is implicit in that
conversation or in that scenario is the
trust between me and you right so I
trust you to do something you trust me
to do something and you know some random
person that says give me five dollars
I'm like oh I've never talked to you
before yeah we just happened right
outside you know right come in here you
know the refugees from this economic
paradigm you know that yeah give me five
dollars man you know right refugees from
the economic paradigm yeah that's
basically what's happening so so in this
scenario there's a reciprocity there's a
mutuality okay and if you really look at
nature you know essentially the Ark of
civilization has been to match our
activity to the cadence of nature we've
been doing that forever right and even
the way we describe things so our
understanding of nature has reflect
in the language in the way we see things
so for example in the industrial age
when we discovered machines to do our
road tasks for us you know we describe
the heart as a pump arm as a lever you
know we looked at things from a very
mechanistic point of view now we keep
talking about my social network you know
so it's actually an evolution we talking
about my social network my neural
network all this network so
understanding mycelial understandings of
how nature works we have a deeper
understanding so at each iteration of
civilization we get closer to how nature
works versus what we think it is right
and so right now it's a very interesting
time because right now nature operates
on mutuality and reciprocity you plant a
seed on the ground and you nurture it
and it grows right so there's a feedback
loop of that way we operate and very
similarly the way we conceive construct
reality is essentially a process of
discovery process of design and
development a process of delivery and
distribution the same thing it's you
know the why what how of how something
works it's the same as is the same way
we construct stories of reality you know
the hero's journey is essentially you
have a calling you go on a quest you
come back with an insight and you inform
the tribe so it's a positive feedback
loop of all of these things circle of
innovation whatever you want to look at
it's the same basic loop same basic loop
of you know let me ask what's going on
let me figure out how you know let me
figure out how to make sense of all this
and then I now that I've made sense of
it I'm gonna bring that back so that we
have all of us have a deeper
understanding okay so this mutuality
reciprocity is kind of our intention we
get sidetracked based on something that
we've created as a way to capture that
so it's not there are no bad guys good
guys you know we evil so-and-so bankers
it's a crisis of perception you're not
seeing the whole picture because all
you're looking at it through your lens
so if I'm in the on the on the driver's
seat of the promise making choice making
capacity I'm only seeing my side of the
equation I'm not seeing the whole
picture I'm not seeing what it takes to
produce I remember what it was to
produce something depends on how I
earned my money right whether you know I
came up from nothing
that's one perception or I came from you
know inherited legacy wealth that's
another kind of perception whatever it
is or I'm in the driver's seat of
actually creating these mechanics so I
have a different lens than the person
who has to work to produce was to keep
on proving you know it's kind of like
it's always I'm putting your capacity in
question I don't trust you until you
deliver you know I'm your employer do
the work then you'll get your paycheck
I'm the investor give me your innovation
and then I'll you know and then I'll
sell your product or you know I'll give
you more funding whatever this this loop
perpetually puts us at odds with one
another we're looking at this whole
thing as a win-lose scenario me versus
you let me get mine then I'll give you
yours you know even in the area of
sustainability even in the area of
actually trying to fix the problems that
we've created it's more about let me
figure it out then I'll give it to you
and then there's a reasoning behind that
way of thinking we and understand where
that comes from but we're at this
juncture now in civilization where that
win-lose generator function does not
serve us if we start from that place of
what's yours what's mine you know so
talking about these fires for example
you know the the you know of the person
who's in the executive seat in in this
country right the the the the way you
just kind of describe like oh you guys
are not doing your job it's not my
problem now this that's a despicable
human being we don't have to talk about
the way that person is but that person
is a result of this win loser loser
generator function it's a result of
somebody who basically what's in it for
me what's in it for me what's in it for
me so as we start to look at this oh
those people they're burning fine
but we don't exist without one another
so this is the real kind of
understanding of our times that we don't
exist in isolation we never did exist in
isolation even our biological beings
there are more microbes in my body than
cells right so we are in
interdependent symbiosis with all that's
around us so we are that we are that in
each with each other and we're that with
the world so interesting we are very
welcome for complexity in motion you
know and complexity basically means that
we're part of many little things that
could change State at any one given time
so you and I are complex beings the way
we organize how we work with each other
is another level of complex social
relationships and how those social
relationships relate to our resources
that we use is another layer of
complexity there's a lot of unknowns you
know [ __ ] can go left we don't know you
know we can make a wrong decisions and
that can have you know a ripple effect
across you know across the whole
ecosystem which is the kind of things
that we're seeing in the way we burn
fossil fuels is the way we are running
this economic paradigm the way the
refugees from the economic system that
we've seen the overproduction of things
how we produce and waste things because
we want to keep prices in a certain
place how we leverage people's capacity
so many things are the end result of a
win-lose thing I win you lose I win you
lose I win you lose let me win and then
I'll help you win even that thing
fundamentally is flawed because a
win-lose generator function leads to
extinction
there is no there's no reciprocity
there's no mutuality and that win-lose
way of thinking if I but instead if I
start to think in a win-win reciprocity
which is what happens when you feel an
iron relationship with one another right
so if we care about each other you know
that my well-being is tied to your
well-being I have an understanding of
that
I don't approach it from that
perspective I approach it like if you do
well I do well if I do well you do well
okay we start to think in those terms
then all that we've created actually
start to serve us and that's kind of the
crux of designing a currency from that
vantage point versus the way we've been
approaching it thus far
and then how do we do that the win-win
design well so okay so do we have assets
that help us to which ones which assets
are the good ones to help us okay the
asset is a really interesting question
right well the ass is the visual ones
that we go oh which ones are good for
this you can put you can throw up
visuals that's fine let's let's look at
it from from a different I mean you can
throw up a visual that's not really
important do you have one that's that's
specifically good for the win-win what's
my question and no not nothing us was
not specific okay okay so the currency
that we're designing is called o and o
is something that all has the both proof
of promise and proof of performance
built into it in other words it's a it's
a way of looking at currency where I can
have promise making capacity so that o
actually without getting getting into
the secret sauce of how it works and all
that but basically you can bios but the
O's don't mean anything until you can
prove the performance against it in
other words you you know within a
project context you're actually proving
that you do the work so and which is
which brings up a very interesting point
about so I buy hours and then whatever
and then how do I prove that I'm
performing well within the context of a
project so project is anything that that
requires more than myself to do just
everyday activities that we already do
right and like like that she's me like
the show like the show so okay so for
this show I would I would I would BIOS
and then we would perform this show and
then what would so you have some
intended outcome of this show right so
you know this show is successful if this
you had someone viewership or retweets
or you know basically you'd want to
understand that this was received this
was received and this was integrated and
change I think you're in the perception
game which is a very that's another
topic in and of itself that's quite
industry right so adding more of the
lenses to an issue adding more of lenses
to an issue being able to see things
from multiple perspectives okay and that
ultimately changes the way we operate in
the world you know yeah but from the
minute it like that you know we all know
about the overview effect the minute we
can see the Earth from space it
fundamentally changes global commerce
global telecommunications everything
with now you have a whole picture of
something you know it's interesting the
year I believe it okay
my numbers could be off but it was in
the round the twenties right when the
year that speedometer came out in in a
moving vehicle it reduce traffic
fatalities by 78 or 79 percent something
like that okay which is very telling
because people didn't know how fast they
were going once they can see how fast
they were going it fundamentally changes
behavior right so this is very
interesting so many interfaces we
already understand look at the weather
if it's cloudy outside or right now with
this fires it looks like Beijing outside
and you know you know what that means so
when you see it we all understand it's a
universal interface okay okay so then
this example with the source so an
example of the O's is got a bunch of O's
because you bought them with currency
well well okay so you can earn them from
doing a problem you can yeah
that's the whole thing so the the
whether it's proof a promise or proof of
performance in either scenario I have
the capacity of creating a form of
currency that is actually current so
this is what I mean by kind of a real
time trust currency it's actually
current because I can trust you to
perform whatever that is because you've
proven that within the context of a
project you know and a project is
something we do together like for
example the show or you know producing
the shirt that where you're wearing I'm
wearing anything that we are doing is
essentially something that a bunch of
humans come together to do
okay now within that context there's
many many loops of okay
I have an idea is that idea good enough
to be you know something we should
produce against then if something that
we need to produce against war the
resources we need to produce that if we
have those resources is that something
that is going to be benefit of is that
going to benefit how people are going to
be receiving it and so is their lack of
a better word is there a market for it
okay so is this going to be received as
is going to create benefit is this
something that's worth creating and who
gets to benefit and why that whole
process of doing that you perform
certain things I perform certain things
somebody else performs another certain
thing and as they do that performance
over time now I know within that context
I can trust them Yeah right for that
specific performance that they've gotten
good at that then then what do I do with
the O's with their performance I'm
trying to get something that they know
how to perform well so they build trust
so I give them us for that how does oh
yeah so so the O's are two things one is
it's just like a regular money you can
use it to actually help something along
so I'm making a promise but I'm also I'm
doing both things I'm not only making
the promise which is the kind of money
that we have crypto is also like that
that I'm making a promise that in the
future it will be worth X right so right
now you know the the global money supply
is less than 5% utility is what I
believe the promise is worth today more
than 95 percent is speculative
that's crazy that's crazy in a world
when we have real-time information of
knowing future information in the
present you know your map tells you down
to the minute what time what time I
arrive at the studio I actually knew
that on my phone right
so my map tells me down to the minute
future information in the present we
exchange real-time information in all
kinds of communication exchanges all the
time so we can know the production cost
of something before the thing is even
produced that's essentially what
crowdfunding crowdsourcing is you put
ending up in escrow and until the thing
is done that nothing gets allocated to
that so we you know we mitigate the risk
of cost of goods sold cost of inventory
cost of you know cost of sales many of
those things that used to be things that
used to hedge bets against in the future
are knowable in the present so all these
things are known okay so the idea of
speculation and in and continuing to
incur more and more gaps in the promise
to production really doesn't make much
sense in the way where we are today
digitally it really doesn't make much
sense because we actually can that no
information is knowable in the present
so in the context of a project just like
we talked about the your capacity to
actually perform is known it is known or
it's knowable okay because I've proven
myself within the context of a project
multiple times so if that is known then
I can trust you to perform that relative
to my project whether that project is
producing something that is to be
consumed or whether that project is
producing something to be experienced
whatever that is within that context I
know you're capacity and not just your
capacity everyone else on the networks
capacity relative to that now what
that's doing is now it's creating a
whole other sort of trust paradigm it
trusts as you all well know is really
there's no algorithm for trust Trust is
essentially my life experience projected
onto a context right so you trust me
based on whatever whatever life you
lived I trust you based on whatever life
I have lived so in that scenario I you
know we trust each other
to let's say do this show beyond that I
don't know if I can trust you you know
if I get if I look like a thousand
dollar investment in something whatever
something we don't know that right so we
don't know what that is but if I proven
that again over and over to take my mom
somewhere who knows right so buddy I'm a
good guy I'm good for it okay so
sometimes it's in first what are my
plants while I'm gone right yeah yeah
what are your plans for your whatever
that's okay so Trust is life experience
projected onto a context I want to know
how the O's work in the performance
economy so the way the O's work is that
the oh is no good until the promise of
performance is accounted for in other
words okay until I know the work that is
going to be done against the O the O has
literally zero network value okay so but
it has promissory value just like
regular money does has potential its
potential just like regular - I'm saying
I'm going to interview ray there's so
there's no worth to the O's then I
interview Ray then there's the work to
the oh so within the context the old
have proven itself right and so so how
do you know how many O's that's worth
and what does that mean that's something
that's determined between me and you
between you and I between you and I or
between between our audience between
whoever is participating within that
project context so within that project
context if we decide this is worth
thousand dollars sure 500 and then what
do we say then then what happens with
those thousand or five hundred dollars
or whatever so now what he knows is
experiences yeah so so that so the idea
is that by doing it like this what we're
doing essentially is creating more and
more capacity to actually make the make
the promise a performance visible so yes
so more we make like it's like you're
showing what level you're at you're
showing you what level you're at and so
if you do that what you essentially do
is you actually create a deflationary
currency so we're used to currencies
that are inflationary you know your
parents will tell you ah you know back
in my day a dollar used to buy me
whatever and now look how I can thread
resumes yeah alright so and there you go
now it's not so much not the case and
this is the this is true everywhere in
the world right so that is not the case
okay and part of the reason that is not
the case is we just we talked about a
little earlier is what happens is if you
had fear on the promise making side the
production is never gonna catch up
because I can it's it takes I have to to
prove my performance I just have to show
my bank account so many promises and so
little performance so now it's so much
performance and less promises but just
lots and lots of performance and then
trying to put in to always on those
performances correct that way you're
always are kind of like your experience
it gets you always get more valuable
over time not less you don't have to let
you know pump the market with more O's
you can actually start to kind of
actually work the other way you can you
know remember there's a movie Benjamin
Button you go backwards you actually go
you you go backwards to essentially you
become the oh right so if I am the
culmination of all the proof of
performance against the proof of promise
then I'm essentially what happens in
real life we are actually walking
examples of social currency and social
capital we get around based on the
nature or the strength of our
relationships which is also fascinating
because the project that you are working
on your reading to yeah it is about the
quality of relationships in the social
networking 3.0 what does that look like
instead of quantity of relationships and
even if you think about okay why focus
on quality versus quantity okay the
whole thing around having quantity of
connections because it increases my
chance of capturing attention if I
capture attention that is convertible to
relevance power relevance power more
promise making a choice making capacity
so right now it's about creating
attention at any cost
this is part of the reason why we're not
trusting our institutions anymore
part of the reason like who is telling
the right story
who is telling the right story who do I
believe you know before you have
venerable institutions whether it's
universities or whether is governments
or what-have-you
yeah that actually procured knowledge
multi-generationally and then they
distributed it out right and so we knew
predictably what was going to happen
next you know we had an idea that okay
under these conditions under this setup
this is what I can expect so I can have
trust in the system for unquote right to
have this thing move forward in that way
okay now the capacity to communicate
that is available to everyone
everyone's a media channel everyone's a
government everyone's you know it's like
so what happens it goes to the lowest
common denominator whoever is best at
generating attention they get the
attention and now they get the choice
making a promise making capacity not the
ones with the knowledge not necessary
the ones with the knowledge yeah the
highest yeah even the premise of this
show like bringing back you know these
kind of long-form intellectual
conversations okay this is missing from
the space thank you thank you Ron
continue right right this is missing
from the space so you're bringing it
back for a reason because the
distribution method of this is much more
fluid so it is actually at the at par
with the people instagramming their
lunch and you're hoping you had that you
know someone might want to talk about
closing the loop on currency rather than
seeing a photo of a salad right sure
sure because they get the same amount of
of recognition even though one is about
something knowledgeable the other one
might be you know maybe I should try to
mate Oh with walnuts on my salad yeah
well that's not necessarily a bad thing
right but the whole point is if you have
a currency system where we're Co
invested in the outcome Co invested in
each other's success okay because in
order for me to have proof of
performance against the proof of promise
I have to close the loop okay so we're
making
win-wins we're making win-win that's
gonna change to a state of abundance in
the world rather than scarcity is
scarcity extraction and all of these
things technology is agnostic it doesn't
you know with a pencil you know you can
write a ransom note or we can create a
masterpiece you know with a hammer you
know I can build a building or I can
bludgeon you to death right either
either as possible so technology is
agnostic so we're afraid of you know
emerging technology super intelligent
machines
machine learning you know AI all of
these kinds of things that are emerging
in our space robotics automation people
fear they're losing their jobs all these
kinds of exponential technical
innovations are coming online if we look
at our you know cryptocurrency
blockchain this whole idea of mining a
proof of promise into existence that in
and of itself is kind of crazy right so
I don't believe because you're not a
centralized institution that you can
actually make the promise so I'm gonna
burn arbitrary computational cycles to
prove that this promise making tool is
real okay as a result I am burning
fossil fuel based power generation
capacities even if I even if I do it
with solar panels well what is the
energy return on investment on solar
panel there is a externality cost so
what happens is within a win-lose thing
we ignore the externalities and like I
said back to the beginning nature is
about reciprocity and mutuality you
cannot ignore some [ __ ] yeah it's gonna
come back full circle you cannot
continue to have an economic paradigm
where you're paying off basically the
equivalent of paying off one credit card
debt with another eventually it comes
full circle you know whatever the
metaphor is you can't keep [ __ ] in
your kitchen and expect it not to smell
right let's let's let's make sure that
we make this example super relatable and
easy to digest as possible okay so so
you have an idea okay you have an idea
to produce something produce this show
whatever is that a good idea
is that a good idea well the people who
would want to see the show or people who
would want to help you produce that show
would basically would have to validate
that idea by uploading something right
okay now if organically I wasn't able to
achieve it I can make promises to
achieve it in other words I can buy the
difference with owes that I would
purchase right if not it doesn't move on
to the next threshold moves on to the
next threshold okay in that scenario I
in that scenario I would actually go
okay in order for me to produce this I
need this kind of expertise who do I
trust that has this kind of expertise
that can actually make this happen for
me so those kinds of people come
together now we speak to an audience do
you want to see this and what is it
worth to you to see something like this
okay so in each instance of this you are
now creating you are now removing the
friction of from an idea to impact
whatever that impact scenario is now the
idea to closing the idea to impact loop
is very very important because by doing
that now you're giving some meaning
behind this construct of a no because it
is it seeing impact gaining owes you
having performance maybe are people
giving you the owes so that you gain
owes in the performance or how does the
how does that work every time I have an
interview I gain Morrow's artists know
you're your own gains more value because
I won oh you're one against more value
and what what is value measured with
sober value is measured with what okay I
want to I want to keep the mechanics at
bay a little bit the reason being is
that we are you know producing a
whitepaper media all of these things to
explain these things in what
more detail from the perspective of
where we are in the world and how does
this benefit the challenges that we see
in front of us so in a way I don't want
to kind of reveal the mechanics of the
whole thing at this stage in the game
but I will I will speak to conceptually
you know what this means what the
implications are I look forward to
talking about the mechanics because I
think there are a lot of people that are
trying to figure out what to move
forward with currencies are the best
move forward and it'll be really good to
actually talk about mechanics because
the mechanics are what's differentiating
between this as well as so many other of
these planetary architectures around
currency and I just want to make sure
that there are no mechanics are are you
know are relatable they're easy for
people to understand but they make total
sense with the proof of performance and
the proof value etc but I get your wide
the win-win and using technology as
something that's beneficial with the
mutual mutuality mutuality and
reciprocity was already kind of built
into the equation right get to abundance
to get to a button I think I think
several people now ours have started to
talk to me about that vision
architecting a system that has that
vision yeah and then the mechanics is
the differentiator between people it's
what are the mechanics that are going to
lead you to success there but I know
your background with especially now
you're looking at these new developing
markets in the Africa and there's just
so much potential with the population
demographics being so so much at the
bottom of the pyramid in terms of age
that there's so many freshly birthed
people in these parts of the world that
it gives a tremendous amount of
potential upswing on their creative
actualization into the world so to be
able to go and bring them the tools and
resources they need to actually succeed
to build that abundance is really
important and I'm glad that you care
about entering those markets with so
many things right so so first of all I
think the whole life even calling it a
bottom of the pyramid
is the result of the one lose generator
function but though I said bottom of
pyramid in terms and I understand any
age yeah and in terms of age as well
demo ground right so 54 percent of the
population the world's population are to
topple the pyramid would be people that
are 80 years old right that's what I
mean yeah so more than half of the
population are people that are in their
20s or younger in Africa in Africa and
India okay so yeah okay now known half
are under 20 more in of the world more
than half of the world's population is
that okay now this is hasn't that always
been that way no this is this is a
recent phenomenon of kind of lots of
births and lots of lots of birds that's
you know justjust generationally what we
have iterated to at this point now these
people are within a win-lose scenario
are not going to be the beneficiaries of
the promise of progress that we've been
living thus far they're simply not and
and part of but don't they have some
promise of progress with their increases
in electricity and food and water right
okay so depends on what lens you look at
so I spent a month and change in India
and I saw this firsthand okay you tell
me how this this scenario actually looks
like it's promising so it's the
workforce of most of the world people
are you know hard-working talented
educated resourceful individuals you
know all in their 20s most of them all
in their 20s working 14 plus hour days
and at the end of it
you're earning one-fifth or one-sixth of
their counterpart in developed parts of
the world
now with that
you are your diet consists of all of the
most profitable food like products you
know the soft drinks the processed foods
and all of that and because again you
disconnected from how nature works to to
what is profitable it's a win-lose
scenario so the win-lose scenario
creates these these monoculture based
agriculture all these and make these
things complicated right so so in India
for example you know less than 40 years
ago used to have two hundred thousand
varieties of rice now there's three okay
now mmm right so which is not just in
India but everywhere so the reason
people have gluten allergies and all
these other things you know as a result
of lack of biodiversity in the crops how
that responds to our our genome how that
responds to our you know genotypes
phenotypes all of these things are you
know there's there's a disconnect
there's there's a there's a systemic
disconnect so as a result so what it
looks like in India is people young
people work all the time every corner
there's a farmer's shop with unregulated
prescription drugs available
over-the-counter and just like you can
buy candy from anywhere okay every
corner there's a diabetic and thyroid
Center which is telling this very
telling of the number of customers that
are actually experiencing that those
health risks okay
you have unregulated products in the
marketplace you know selling cigarettes
that are 30 percent tobacco rest as
fillers so a lot of these things
pesticides all kinds of stuff is going
on and the quality of life and quality
of health you get a cold you get
antibiotics it is horrific and even the
waste you know there's a company in
Hyderabad you know puts out this guy
ready puts out like 100,000 times more
Pharma waste into the water this is in
the drinking supply so people are
getting sick and dying and they're doing
the
of the world the stuff that we don't
want to do the hardcore database
management stuff the system architecture
stuff and and your being promised a
lifestyle that is technically
unattainable even within this capitalist
paradigm so you know in the in the major
metropolitan areas like let's say like a
city like Mumbai you have this thing
where you have these flats that are you
know half a million or more in value
they're part of these kind of societies
that have ten thousand five thousand
units okay you're bringing in water from
outside you're generating energy by
burning fossil fuels and it had fifty to
sixty percent occupancy and the rent is
equivalent to somebody's monthly income
so what ends up happening is people are
basically living like roommates in the
roommate situation much like what's
happening in the Bay Area here with
advanced degrees in education they have
an aspirational model that is
unattainable and you have a real estate
or investment model that's based on
speculation that I'm just trying to fill
these units but I you know just from all
looks of things this thing is going to
collapse so there's some real
unsustainable processes and systems that
are going on around the planet totally
right yes right there's also some really
good societal progress that's being made
amount of people getting access to
electricity electricity internet all
these kinds of things or sure yeah yeah
yeah and getting access to clean water
you mean disease-free this type of stuff
but I but I totally agree with you that
there is a different sort of
architecture that needs to come into
play to ameliorate the problems that
your listing there's a whole there's a
whole bunch that that that can be
unpacked about what we're talking about
right now and what you're producing here
is just one one way to tell yeah so we
don't know when it's aware so we'll talk
about it we're a platform agnostic we're
actually creating a protocol not a
platform because platform again is about
when lose
it's about silos it's about data silos
that kind of hoard information rather
than share information right so we are
creating a platform agnostic or platform
independent protocol if you forward that
slide I can we can we can speak to it
it's the one with the hand but the one
with the hand couple forward yeah
probably a couple forward there right
there we go okay so so this way we can
integrate so okay before I talk about
this I mean I'm gonna just just come
back to the topic of this huge potential
of the of the underserved okay so you
have people in these regions that have
ideas because the the world that is
promised to them if you're smart enough
you realize that's unattainable yeah
they're not smart enough to realize it's
unattainable you're still working your
ass off and not getting the rewards I
feel as though what you were saying
about that is you know quite true in
many ways that it is extremely difficult
to to have a promise be fulfilled an
unsustainable sort of way that's
horrible
but for these promises to be fulfilled
in more sustainable ways it's kind of
the path that we're trying to pave is
that if you want these these greater
standards of living in a sustainable way
through a sustainable systems
architecture more and more people on the
planet can get these more and more
people can on the planet can get these
and it is not only attainable we
actually our collective intelligence
comes into play so you can you may have
an idea but you don't know if that idea
is relevant to the network and so by
creating a protocol based approach what
you're essentially doing is you are able
to drop an idea
see if that idea attracts we talked
about this theme before in terms of
projects so see if that idea tracks and
we can kind of what I like to call
Twitter eyes it and what I mean by that
is this is that you know if you look at
the evolution of communication or
evolution of any technology it is
removing the friction between intention
and impact right so before if you had to
produce this show you'd have to have a
television station
you know all the capital investments
said I was being a lot of
democratization a lot of them helped a
lot yeah yeah and one of the also talked
about the protocols that you were
talking about earlier not a platform but
a protocol but that's part of the
mechanics and part of your white paper
yeah so but but I will speak to that so
basically what we realized is that the
the there's certain there's components
that actually enable people to produce
relevant applications for their context
for the scenario that they own so for
all of these underserved people whether
you're in a space of creating
agricultural prosperity you know kind of
decentralized democratize access to
agricultural innovations and a little
enabling that to scale or in urban
population I may have ideas but I don't
know if my ideas are good enough to
actually be beneficial to the network
okay so I need ways of amplifying those
ideas I need I need ways of validating
those ideas
I need ways of producing those ideas I
need a way to connect the education
around those ideas what should I be
learning and what should I be producing
and how do I learn and how do I produce
and so this whole lens of actually
project-based education project-based
entrepreneurship project based
employment project-based something where
there's a tangibility in other words
proof of performance already is implicit
in that activity project-based and proof
of performance go hand in go hand in
hand and then that's where the okk comes
into the valley that's that's exactly
that's where the o comes in to be a
value around that and so our protocol is
essentially the protocol is is the one
protocol which means one network
entrustment so instead of an idea of a
bond which is the DEP instrument because
I don't know the work that's going to be
done against it the one network
entrustment is essentially a proof of
performance that is actually backing
that instrument and yeah so as a result
when you share within the context of Oh
based project learning environment
whether it be in agriculture whether it
be in you know urban settings or whether
it be in you know story creation
whatever what-have-you your profile
value increases so it enables you to
actually share information rather than
hoarded today we don't share IP this
whole thing about intellectual property
so then so now we have in each
individually within the protocol a value
ascribed to us and then depending on how
many project-based experiences we
partake in how much knowledge we share
how much that value is then that we we
gain in a higher Oh ascribe to us based
on how other people rank these projects
like how they upload them and whatnot
right exactly okay so you're kind of in
a sense is like this is an it's like you
said it's not a platform it's a protocol
the product so so in this protocol we
all seven have billion people have a
value ascribe to them based on how many
projects they're getting involved in how
many how much value they're bringing and
then other people are uploading on the
value and the projects and then your
o--'s increase and increase in ascribed
value and then that's how you become
maybe a figure of a vac of authority of
power something of that people trust
yeah very much like how real life works
you know very much like you know we
can't say that same thing about money
right we can't say the same thing about
money because them because in like in
the context of money the proof of
performance is a guess it's yeah it's a
guess right now let's see so that today
we know I can agree a dollar is worth a
dollar ba have been an inheritance or it
together it's it's a guess it's against
you they might not have been that this
person has actually performed to attain
the the money right interesting
right so what we're doing is we're
taking guess worth will wrap after this
last bit and then we'll continue on
another conversation soon yeah wonderful
yes so so we're becoming guess we're
taking out the guesswork of economics to
a network effect of economics so the
network so now the protocol is
essentially the components of engagement
within a project environment so it's so
there's many things that we can create
we already have the kind of code set and
the baseline for these these five things
so one is the idea of identity okay so
my sovereign identity so I can kind of
come back and go back to that slide
please one more time yeah went there and
we're gonna we're about to wrap so the
whole idea of identity is my sovereign
self so if I sovereignty means I can act
within my capacity my maximum agency
within a context that's how I would deal
with complexity the more stuff you know
the more you can respond to some wait
wait how would we live sorry how do we
live with a value that is ascribed to us
of value of oh how do I get food and
shelter and water yeah so it's so in
context so we're basically allowing
people to design their own applications
using these toolkits so which is one is
how do I create a sovereign identity
second is how do i how do I participate
in interchange how do I produce a
project with other people in my network
okay how do I manage those investment
flows it's a multi asset multi token way
of managing those flows how do I
interact or communicate with one another
so kind of a decentralized telephony
solution there could be a spinach stand
somewhere and then then I have earned a
certain amount of value or owes by being
performance and they have as well yeah
and then how do we exchange that you're
you're actually understanding the
symbiosis between that spinach stand and
your lifestyle because because you're
now seeing how that relates to what you
are doing before that person is earning
money you're earning money and you're
not you have a bunch of blind spots you
don't know what they're gonna do with
their money you don't know what you're
gonna do with their money here your your
fates are aligned or Co invested so
eventually so if someone's o--'s are not
valued enough they haven't performed yet
then they can't get they can make up the
difference with promissory notes like so
so they can make up they can buy into it
and say you know what okay I haven't
proven myself and so this is how we
transition from this existing fiat world
okay I'm not knowing you know what the
future value of this thing is even if
I'm horde and a lot of money today okay
it could very well go the way of
Venezuela I think there's a slide in
there somewhere with the value of the
Venezuelan currency right now it's
pretty crazy right so it's not even
worth a toilet paper it's the one in
this it's a big stack of money next to a
piece of toilet paper right right so
right now that that thing is worth less
than a roll of toilet paper that amount
of money right okay is that that's
actually true that's actually true today
that's so horrible that's crazy right so
so basically that is so so so adorable
so it's meaningless so you want to kind
of reverse this flow you want to reverse
this flow by actually creating a
deflationary currency and that has a
whole bunch of other implications and if
you want to break now we can come back
to that but there's a whole bunch of
implications as to how you know we move
forward in society because a lot of the
things that we're seeing you know
including the UN SDGs there's
symptomatic of this win-lose game this
win-lose game with exponential technical
capacity towards a win-lose game is does
not create mutuality and reciprocity it
actually accelerates the opposite so
what we create is I have exclusivity and
you do not I have more and more
exclusivity you have less and less
exclusivity and the more I create that
the more we disconnect from each other
the more we disconnect from nature more
we disconnect from what would create a
quality of life for us going forward so
if you want to put that back you have to
get to the very root essence of it as
you know this is no good until you can
prove the performance if you do that
then everything else kind of you know
kind of recirculates around that yeah
yeah I have a lot more questions about
the mechanics and protocols that we'll
need to get into Mehran since you're
training Sarah as well
you guys are both back there do you
would you like to us the rapper would
you be okay with would you alright so so
we'll just go a little longer just to I
just I want it because I think we
finally started getting to the essence
of what you want to get done it took a
while for me to at least get it yeah um
but I liked when you added a project
based endeavoring alongside the
alongside the platform of of earning
ascribing value to people based on how
much performance they've done now now
that that starting to make sense and the
performance is based in these projects
project-based performance and you get
ascribed a value even oh okay there's
still so much more to understand about
make it the mechanics and protocols
about you know how does one actually get
electricity how does one get food get
water all this type of stuff and if you
have if you if you're scribed a certain
value of oh then you get it and then
they for some reason or giving it to you
yeah yeah so so it's a lot of things you
know the way we okay so if you get to
the root of something and you just flip
it 180 it's going to affect it's going
to have like a butterfly effect on the
entire paradigm of how we've been living
to date okay so right now is is like I
said we're living very precarious and
interesting times right so climate
change is upon us
you know there's 80 to 80 trillion that
I've been in trillion or billion that
I've been invested towards climate
change action
I believe it's looked at probably has to
be billions yeah bill yeah yeah billion
that that's been allocated to that but
you don't need that much to actually
reverse
tied you if you if you fundamentally
change it at the root it will have a
whole bunch of spiraling effects around
it so when you talk about how do I get
my electricity how do I get my food how
do I get my transportation if there are
certain assumptions in place around
those questions okay there are totally
because we produce we have producing yes
so so now it becomes the question of who
produces the food who produces the
transportation who owns this asset you
know who manages this asset what is the
game that they're playing in order for
them to be in business you know so all
these things like when you change
something at the root
it has reciprocal effects across the
entirety of how we wound up civilization
this way so it's it creates the bizarro
version of the world that we live in
today so in other words like let's say
you have a shared economy service like
an uber okay right now you trust a
construct like uber to be able to
deliver so you'll be able to trust the
driver trust the passenger to be able to
get you from point A to point B because
then you can create all kinds of
peripheral businesses and now if I can
authenticate a user's identity okay and
they're their old value is tied to my Oh
Val you in other words they're proof of
performance is tied to the proof of
promise of whatever that unit of
exchanges in that in that space okay
what happens to who gets what and why is
fundamentally different so a bunch of us
if somebody's got a car somebody can
drive and somebody somebody needs a ride
we can make our own and that's the
fundamental difference we can actually
make our own of things is decentralized
agency and democratizing capacity is is
the norm not the exception this is this
has been happening throughout
civilization for as long as we can
remember right so we have more and more
capacity no I want to know yeah I want
to know how this work if I you know from
my normal perception which I've been
born into
everyone has been now was that when I
want to get on the bus they go to the
next place that I want to go to that I
need to pay two dollars to get onto that
bus now how would that system be
architected so that the that the owner
of that asset is willing to accept me as
a passenger on to that bus without an
exchange of two dollars what would that
look like okay so if your family owned a
restaurant do you pay to eat there maybe
maybe not
okay now okay so I see how that changes
things so if you own the asset of the
bus you wouldn't pay to get on the bus
you would and okay so now and the the
objective of the bus is is
transportation as a service it's not to
make money it's to transport it's to
transport but then also to make enough
to be able to correct add another bus
route to help you get two more please
correct correct so so there's two things
at play here so one is okay the one is
that the whole thing is to transport
people and the proof of performance is
how well are you transporting people
okay and how satisfied the transport
ease and the transport or transport
orders are performing within that loop
within that scenario
okay so you as a transporter the bus you
know people who are running the
operations of the bus or producing the
bus or you know creating the bus routes
okay in one category if you're riding
the bus using the bus you're another
category before you're on your own
I'm paying you're doing and so I'm you
know distinction between the resolves
cells right yeah in this scenario
actually you are now co-creating this
transportation reality okay okay and how
does it work so that means that if I'm
if I am adding value to making
transportation a better experience for
everyone involved then the value of my
increases if I'm adding value to make
transportation
more efficient and accessible or kind of
minimizing the waste in that
transportation loop that also makes so
that it that that also makes so people
are like up voting my bus route and then
I'm able to somehow add more bus routes
based on people up voting me and then
people can yeah this is like real-time
supply and demand meaning rather than
the speculation of I'm gonna need this
much bus bus routes I might need these
people to do this yes right so you're
actually understanding it because you're
negotiating it on the fly you're
actually realizing what each other need
because both of you are Co invested in
creating more value for the for the O's
that you're using to make that thing
happen your individual value in the
network increases the better I am
participating the better I can prove my
performance relative to that outcome so
the more I do that the the easier it is
so my bus ride becomes free or actually
I'm adding value by optimizing the bus
route I'm adding value by manufacturing
the bus parts I'm adding value to
creating a more efficient bus or you
know less you know material intensive
bus or you know less you're not looking
at the whole thing from a whole
different perspective because now the
whole game is different that's actually
that's probably the hardest part about
the way that you think is to be able to
think about it from a whole different
perspective because you're so entrenched
into the money game that it's so
difficult to take a step out of the
money game and envision civilization
using things differently with always
instead of money because even the way
that bitcoins and cryptocurrencies work
in so many ways that these token ah
mixes and so many ways similar to money
and exchanging again just tokens or
coins forced goods or services again
it's just a again a very much so it's
not a it's not a system like this Oh
system is so in the Oh system everything
is win-win everything is progressing
moving I just see I see it as something
that moves forward like a linear time
would yeah like oh it's constantly
moving forward so I've
things constantly win winning yeah
that's how I see it
but now the last question is then how do
how do the exchanges work as everything
moves forward that that's the way I
think I think they self adjust
I think this self adjusts relative to
context right so okay so so there's
constantly a dynamic way that it's
interplaying based on what people want
in real time what they need in real time
Kurt and whatnot Chris okay it's in your
best interest
the assumptions behind the actions why
am I doing this
so what about the old values are
shifting relative to human value
relative to human value right so why am
I doing this what benefit am i creating
for the whole because the more I create
benefit to the network as a whole the
more so my capacity my my contribution
determines my capacity more the more
effectively I can contribute and more my
proof of performance as accounted for
the more I'm valued in the system so I
am much more so you're basically
gamifying people to contribute rather
than to consume for personal purposes
you're actually yes that's really
important that's very important that's
actually probably the most one of the
most important parts of everything that
we've been talking about yeah gamifying
it so that people want to contribute
rather than consume right consumption is
a natural human thing do you want to sue
but to what end
to what end if you only consume you
never contribute that's not good if you
yeah yeah you got to consume electricity
and water in order to live so there you
go so you need to do that at least but
yeah when you're gamify contribution
again because it's based on proof of
performance you have to perform yeah
then that's where you get a system
that's constantly moving forward like
that I totally do but so there's a food
water energy like if we talk about all
these things okay the way we produce
them the way we distribute them all
these things everything in our national
Wars materials and energy right so it's
really the equation between material and
energy so human energy human intention
you know like all of these things are
built with somebody saying so when we
talk about like what kind of ass
are you talking about okay asset is a
really funny concept you know asset is
part perception and part production
against that perception right so like
something like this right used to be a
bunch of dirt and glass less than a
hundred years ago you didn't know that
this could be used as a global
telecommunication device okay that you
have access to so many things using a
device like that so that never existed
in the space but in order for that thing
to become an asset one you had to
perceive the possibility of something
like that and then you'd have to
actually produce the components to make
that thing right and so similarly all
the things that we use today the way you
use energy dwell you use water the way
we distribute any any goods or services
okay all these things are based on some
fundamental assumptions of who gets what
and why so if it's about me
winning in order for me to survive then
that looks one kind of way but it looks
completely differently if I say in order
for me to produce this thing we have to
look at it how this is a win-win if it's
not a win-win this cannot move forward
and if it cannot move forward then it's
not in the benefit of so you're actually
kind of assumption checking yeah fact
checking you know relevance checking
built into the design of the game itself
so the project context actually create
that no creating the win wins creating
the women okay so now first of all last
thought and then we'll read yes last
thought is this is not meant to be
prescriptive like I said this is not a
platform this is not meant to be
something that okay you know I figured
it out or we figured it out and now
we're going to share this with the world
it's not so much about that it's more
about kind of putting out something into
the world that allows us to now
participate and create value where there
is direct need so coming back to India
Africa underserved markets all around
the world is there are many many people
who are suffering at the at their
economic refugees at a global level
so there's they're suffering from this
economic paradigm
win-lose they have a lot to contribute
they have a lot to produce okay there
are a lot of education project-based
learning project-based education project
base improving the quality of people's
lives that are present right now we are
engaging in actually doing those pilot
projects in those specific locations so
the the thing is a lot of the questions
you ask me yes we have ideas we have
frameworks we have understanding but we
really don't know and the whole thing is
there's no way I can know or you can
know are the people that we're working
with our team you know we cannot
possibly know everything but we can ask
the questions so that we can invite in
better questions that reveal better
answers and that that perpetually create
a whole other win-win loop of how do we
respond to the catastrophic changes that
are in front of us you know do we look
that literally we I mean right now
yeah the loop in answer to the big
problems of society right right so
you're working yeah exactly so there's a
project context is a starting point
generating interest and investment
towards actually making these things a
reality because where we are today we're
at an early stage we have some baseline
technology some baseline design some
baseline way of producing you know local
applications etc that's just a starting
point we still need to be able to tell
the story of what a win-win scenario
looks like yes you know yes yes because
next time we'll not only talk about all
the mechanics and protocols in more
detail but I want to go to the bus story
and the restaurant story because you
give a really good example of you know
if your family owns a restaurant do you
pay no answers no so then you know what
does it look like when you adjust these
variables these different ways as you
move things forward if looking across
the world how do how do you make right
and how do you make this a
civilizational progress and win-win yet
for people yeah and then the critical
part is we don't have time
and here's the thing you know so I'll
just leave on the more note of time
right yeah so when we're seeking wealth
we're see essentially taking quality of
time when we're seeking recognition for
our contribution were seeking quality of
time so this time is running out under
the win-lose function when a win/win
function we have everything and time and
so that's very very important so so
that's equality of time is everything
it's about perceptions actually
understanding ourselves our
consciousness relative to the whole so
this is a very important thing because
the way we're going right now literally
from every do everything that it looks
like it looks like we have nothing we're
running out of time we're gonna go
extinct the extinction area vent is upon
us so we can see them
Ron Ron loves extinct Ronnie loves
extreme but I think we can do complete
opposite have been the complete opposite
we can instead of dodo we can thrive so
literally we can we can live in a very
abundant fashion where we take care of
me and you because we make ourselves
accountable we create mutuality and
reciprocity once again we close the loop
hence this whole idea of a circular
currency thus the Oh because it's a full
circle way of understanding reality it's
a full circle way of being civil to one
another it's a full circle way of
reestablishing the trust between you and
me and me and you n to the way we
organize things and to the way we relate
to nature so now we're coming back to
who we are already so we're not
reinventing anything we're actually
coming back to who we are we're coming
back to zero because that's where we've
always been I love the idea of thinking
about a future where there's so much
prosperity that time becomes this just
we can just chill through time and do
time in a way that is not the same
paradigm that time is now correct I look
I really look forward to that ray it's
so exciting to talk to you about solving
one of humanity's most pressing
challenges that will then solve so many
other of the pressing challenges
and it's kind of the roots it's the
roots of all the problems is this the
way we close the loop on currency and
the way that we create abundance through
win-win it's very interesting and I'm
glad that you're tackling this is
extremely difficult and that's why as
I'm asking questions I'm learning and
it's hard to balance all these variables
and conversations as you're teaching but
there will be you know when we come back
there will be more that you will have
done and developed and I will come back
with more questions and a better
understanding of things repoter thank
you so much thank you so much so yeah
it's argued to us it's like this has
been such a pleasure really appreciate
you a lot thank you thank thank you
thank you thank you thank you everyone
for tuning in we really appreciate it
let us know what you think in the
comments about this ray would also love
to hear from you the links are all below
in the bio go and check out Ray's work
please also thank you Ron thank you
Sarah for producing and directing we
greatly appreciate you and go and build
the future go and manifest your dreams
into the world people thank you so much
and we will see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]